[MUSIC PLAYING]
AMOGH UMBARKAR: Good afternoon,
ladies and gentlemen.
My name is Amogh Umbarkar.
I have here with me also
Balaji Krishna, my colleague.
And as we are set
in a movie theater,
we will walk you through a
movie of SAP's data management
journey.
Also, how we are trying to
bring best of both worlds
from SAP and Google
in an offering to you.
So brief agenda, how we are
going to walk you through,
in terms of what do we see from
the enterprise data landscapes?
What is SAP Data
Hub, the product
that we are going
to walk you through?
How we are working
and collaborating
with Google Cloud?
And a few customer examples.
And of course, we want
to keep it interactive
or also have questions
from you guys.
So let's go through.
As you can see, here is
the kind of evolution,
in terms of the enterprise
intelligence on one axis,
as towards the data
diversity on the other one.
You all know that we have
seen more OLTP as a start,
where the transaction
processing was the first step
into the enterprise world.
We as SAP started our journey
also from there onwards.
Then we saw a push and
move towards enterprise
BI, or reporting.
And that's when the OLAP
world came into being.
And as we are
moving more and more
towards heterogeneous landscapes
and more diverse data,
we are seeing a multi-faceted
data management requirement.
We are seeing also technologies
like machine learning, AI, IOT,
being used as well.
And that is where it becomes
now more and more interesting
how we can address all these
kind of data management
challenges also in the future.
Just to bring a little
context as to why and how data
is changing the world,
here is an example
where last year, a judge
gave a ruling in Ohio
that the data from a
pacemaker could be used
against an investigation for--
fire insurance investigation.
You all might have seen that,
how one father had reached out
to the marketing
team from Target,
when they were sending
some commercials related
to pregnancy.
And later he found out that
they were actually not wrong.
Their predictions
were true, and they
knew more, or had more data
points, on his household.
In terms of movies, we have
seen that the data science
teams have been collecting
more and more data, just
like in this kind of a
set-up, when it gets exciting,
or when it is scary, and try
to see that which scenes are
creating more effect, and
bring that into action
for their next productions.
Also, from Spotify, we have
seen that they are using it
to bring out more ad business.
We have seen also that
after Brexit, they
sent out these kind of ads.
And you know, it's end of
the world kind of a thing,
or what you see onscreen
about Valentine's Day.
And of course in
Japan, a land where
there are a lot
of earthquakes, we
have seen as well that
even apps on the iPhone
are being used to
gather data and then
try to predict as
to what can be done,
or what is the kind of
intensity that is happening.
But now, coming
towards a little bit
in terms of the corporate world
as well, what we are seeing
is a picture like this.
There are a lot of silos.
Data is separated.
And what we see also is,
with mergers and acquisitions
scenarios coming in, it
adds to another challenge.
And further it up now with
the kind of open-source world,
or Big Data and
Hadoop scenarios,
it adds further
complexity to this.
And it becomes really a
big challenge for the teams
to see that how they can avoid
duplication of data, how they
can avoid unnecessary
movement of data,
and go through bringing
all these silos together
for a single version of truth.
What we are seeing
is also an explosion.
Just to give you a
context, in the last 5,000
years, the amount of
data that was created,
which we already
exceeded in the last--
2016, 2017 years.
And it's predicted, by 2025,
it will become humongous.
It is expected to be
163 zettabytes of data.
So manually actually
analyzing this data
is simply out of the question.
That's where we want to
automate as much as possible
and bring value from the
data to make sense and have
intelligent insights.
So when this volume
of data comes in,
understanding that data,
or finding patterns,
and so on, is also
equally important.
What you see onscreen
here is some picture
where you can add context.
You can add some
water, and you can
see that maybe it's
a seagull, when
you build some context
around the data
and add some meaning to that.
But at the same time, if
you add a different context,
then you are able to
see a different picture
and bring out a different
meaning from that.
Of course, a
skilled veterinarian
can differentiate between this,
and that is the kind of job
that data management, data
governance, data science
kind of roles are today facing.
And with this, what we
tried to do from SAP's side
is we got feedback from
some of the customers,
as well as from some
analysts, and with the study
also from KPMG, we
realized that there
are at least five principles,
if you think from data side.
There is data visibility.
Almost three-fourths
of the customers
said that, yes, this
is definitely complex,
and that limits their agility.
Data quality is a big concern.
Most of the CEOs are
saying that OK, this
is where we are basing
our decisions on.
And for innovation, they
are saying that they're not
getting most out of the data.
Also, in terms of if
you ask them that,
are you knowing how much data
is relevant for your decisions?
They're not even able to
give rough percentages.
This is a big, big
problem that we sense,
and where we could bring
out some offerings.
DCO is a factor, compliance.
We had GDPR coming in Europe.
We have [INAUDIBLE].
So all these things
will definitely
shape up, in terms of the
challenges for our customers.
That's where SAP came out with
a different kind of a thought
process.
And we wanted to now
see how we can address
all these challenges together.
How can we build
a kind of 360 view
to give them a view across
their enterprise data, which
means that it can be enterprise,
also the open-source world.
How can we seamlessly integrate
data quality capabilities
in there?
How can we give them
also all the tools
that are available today
to drive their innovation
initiatives in a
very agile manner?
At the same time, we wanted
to avoid the data redundancy.
We wanted to avoid
the high cost of data.
So we wanted to optimize that
by decentralized data processing
as well, and of
course, in the end,
to give them the confidence
and get them to be
compliant with their data sets.
So what SAP has come out
with, its new offering,
we launched late last
year SAP Data Hub.
We are trying to help
our customers become
more and more data-driven.
What you see here on
the left-hand side
is the SAP world with
SAP HANA as the core
of the digital platform.
And we have on the other
side the open-source world.
We are trying to help now
everyone right from data
discovery, in terms of
metadata governance,
with the orchestration, with
the very kind of agile data
pipelining capabilities.
You will see it
also in demo later.
And at the same
time, we are trying
to expand the reach
into the connectivity,
and also get out the
reach into the cloud
infrastructure providers.
Google is a very close
partner, so we are working
with Google Cloud team as well.
In terms of architecture,
here is what you see.
We are on the layer below,
addressing all the data
storages.
It can be on-premise.
It can be in the Hadoop store.
It can be in the raw store.
It can be in the
cloud store as well.
And on top of
that, you will have
the runtime from SAP Data Hub.
That is where we are
also using Kubernetes,
so you heard a lot from
Diane [? Green ?] today
about Kubernetes,
and Sundar as well,
to see how we are then
seamlessly integrating
that to give you the means to
have that elasticity as well.
And then we are
trying to connect it
into also all the SAP
applications as we go on,
as well as we are giving
you REST APIs to connect in,
if you want to connect to any
other application as well.
On top, then you
are seeing how we
are trying to bring in
capabilities towards metadata
cataloguing, towards data
discovery, how we can have
a one-stop-shop to also
monitor, schedule, and get all
the landscape administration.
And you will see
also in the demo
how easily you can bring
and build data pipelines
and define how and where
the data should flow.
In terms of example with the
flow-based big data management,
here is how you can see there
can be multiple sources.
When comes in the
heterogeneity, you
can have data which is
raw data, but it is now
increasingly becoming important
for your enterprise decisions.
You can bring in
that stream data in.
You can combine it
with your master data.
You can have your
data provisioning done
in a distributed environment.
And to do all this,
you are starting
from injection or
collection of the data.
Then you want to refine the
data, bring in the structure,
especially for the raw
data, make a model,
and then bring it
out for consumption.
And then when you deploy
that, you can automate that.
You can reuse that.
It's very easy to get in there.
And without further
ado, I would like
to then bring in Balaji, who
can talk a little bit in terms
of also what we are doing
in the hybrid cloud,
and walk you through a demo.
BALAJI KRISHNA:
Thank you, Amogh.
Just want to make sure that--
OK, perfect.
I just want to make
sure the mic is on.
So continuing from
where Amogh left off,
we're seeing this
rise of hybrid cloud.
Obviously, when you heard
the keynote this morning,
like one of the
speakers was mentioning,
eight out of 10
customers still look
at a multi-cloud and
hybrid environment
where a lot of
assets are on-prem,
but they're gradually
migrating over to the cloud.
And we see this happening across
different cloud environments,
primarily GCP and Google
being one of the main partners
for SAP in this journey.
And as part of this
journey, what we've realized
is the main advantage
for a lot of customers
when migrating to the cloud
is how easily they can migrate
the workloads without having
to worry about the whole DevOps
aspect of it.
So it's moving from a DevOps
to a no-operational kind
of experience.
And that's what is enabling
a lot of our customers,
and SAP is a company which
has been in the service
for around 46 years.
So we have a lot of customers
who still have on-prem,
but we see that there
is a gradual migration
from our existing customer base
to a cloud kind of environment.
Obviously, a lot of new
customers that we are getting
are primarily cloud-only.
But there are a lot
of on-prem customers,
and for them, we provide
this choice, especially when
trying to manage their data more
efficiently when the data is
spread across cloud, on-prem,
and multi-cloud environments.
And what we try to provide
is this capability of best
of both worlds, because again,
putting the emphasis on hey,
I still have my
ERP system, which
I'm in the process of
upgrading, migrating
from ECC system, SAP ERP
system, to S/4 cloud, which
is our digital code.
But in the interim, I want to be
able to bring in the data that
is on-prem, and also combined
with other applications which
are running on the cloud,
whether it has SAP Concur
or SAP [INAUDIBLE],, which
is cloud-native applications
that SAP has.
So how do I bring
in the data which
is sitting in all
these different layers
and make some sense out
of it, make insights?
And that's where Data Hub
provides this capability on how
we can leverage Data Hub
to build these pipelines,
and beyond that, also talk
to big data systems, or data
lakes, where when you're doing
something like a data lineage
or impact analysis.
It's not enough if
you're just looking
at your traditional relational
data which is primarily
data at rest, but
you also want to look
at the data in
motion, which could
be data coming from IOT stream.
It could be coming
from web logs.
It could be social media data.
So how do I bring that lineage
across my different artifacts,
starting from a BI
dashboard or analytics
report that I'm looking
at, and try to point that
to a source of origin
which could be, hey,
this data came from
SAP ERP system.
But now it is residing in an
HDFS file as a Parquet format.
So it's very important for us to
combine these two worlds, which
is the on-prem and the
cloud, and especially
when we talk about these
multi-cloud environments,
and support different
kinds of workloads.
Like I said, it could be
the IOT streaming workloads,
or it could be advanced
analytics, which
has now migrated to the
whole machine learning
AI kind of workloads.
And finally, a
basic cloud storage,
where I'm looking
at a data aging,
data tiering
strategy, where I want
to push my cold data into
a cloud or a frozen state.
So how do I ensure that I
build a pipeline which can also
bring in the data
from a frozen state,
combine that with hot
data, in-memory data,
that we have in
SAP HANA, which is
our central core of
the digital platform?
So we have collaborated with
Google on multiple aspects.
But one of the
primary things here
is, how do we leverage GKE,
primarily the Kubernetes
engine, but beyond that, GKE?
And that's where we
have a lot of customers
who are running
Kubernetes on-prem,
whether it's through
support from Redhat or SUSE.
But it was interesting to hear
this morning at the keynote
that now we'll have
GKE on-prem as well.
So a lot of our
customers are going
to be excited, because
they're already
on the journey to using GKE.
And for us, we've been working
with Kubernetes for almost two
years now, and even before the
0.1 release was made available.
So we've gone through
the ups and downs,
and it's interesting
to see the adoption,
in terms of how Kubernetes
is being adopted
not just across the customers,
but also across other partner
landscapes.
So for us, it's
important that we
ensure that this
Kubernetes allows
us to build more and
more as we deliver
Data Hub as a service in
the future, where today it's
available as infrastructure
as a service.
But we are looking at a managed
service, where you can come in
and you can buy
the compute hours.
And you just need this compute
to build a pipeline which
does the cleansing and refinery
task for a data scientist
for them to run their
data scientist workloads.
And as you've heard in the
several talks, especially
when we talk about ML and AI
and data science, almost 70%
of those tasks are
related to, I want
to ensure that I've cleaned the
data, I've cleansed the data,
I have the right kind of data,
before I can actually hand it
over to my data scientists.
So data scientists are also
working as data engineers.
And with a tool
like Data Hub, we
simplify that capability
for a data scientist,
for him or her to go in and
build those specific data
scientist workflows, which
is one of the use cases
Amogh is going to be
talking about in the future,
and one of the next slides.
I also want to bring out
this partnership that we're
doing with Google and Cisco.
And I think you heard some of
these, again, at the keynote.
SAP has been working as one
of these triangular partners
in this initiative
for almost a year now.
And it's great to
see that we already
have our first version of
the customers who are looking
at this, and they're already
gaining a lot of benefits,
in terms of enabling
GKE along with Google
Cloud as a hybrid cloud
running on Cisco platform.
So this is really great for
us, to share this information
with our customers,
in terms of Data Hub
being one of the first
applications from SAP
which is able to take
advantage of this partnership
between Cisco and Google.
And finally, before
I go to the demo,
I just want to kind of
set the stage for the demo
that we are going to
be talking about today.
Primarily, this is,
again, a collaboration
for one of our customers that
we did between Google and SAP,
where we're taking
in the data from
point-of-sales information.
So we have
point-of-sales data that
is being streamed in
through Google Cloud
Platform, specifically Pub/Sub.
The output of that
Google Pub/Sub
is being returned
into Google BigQuery.
And again, this pipeline is
being managed using Data Hub.
And the Google
BigQuery data is being
consumed in SAP HANA as a
data virtualization layer.
This is where we talk about
HANA as being that broader
information fabric,
or in-memory fabric,
or the logical data
warehouse, where
what we are enabling
from Data Hub is,
leave your data wherever it is.
Whether it's in your Google
cluster or your on-prem,
we allow you to do the pushdowns
to wherever the data is, so
that you do the heavy
lifting where the data is,
and then we bring
it, do the joins
that are required
before we can make
that available for visualization
through your favorite BI tool
or dashboarding tool.
So let me switch to the demo
before I can hand it over
to Amogh for the use cases.
So what you're seeing here--
before that, actually.
I wanted to show the BigQuery
demo first, before we go into--
so what we are seeing here
is a big data analytics demo
partnership between
Data Hub and BigQuery.
So as I mentioned earlier,
we are streaming data
from point-of-sales across
different retail stores in US.
And this data is being
streamed through a Pub/Sub.
And Data Hub is used as a
configuration management
for connecting this Pub/Sub
and for streaming the data.
Oh, you're not able to see it?
Oh.
Sorry about that.
Thank you, Amogh.
OK, so this is the architecture
diagram that I showed earlier.
And primarily, what
we're doing here
is we are leveraging Data Hub.
And this is the Data
Hub Pipeline Modeler.
So here, what you
see is I'm reading
the data from Google storage.
And I'm streaming the data
up into a Google Pub/Sub.
And the output of
that Pub/Sub is
being consumed into a
Google BigQuery, which
in turn is being accessed
through a HANA calculation
view.
So for folks who are familiar
with SAP HANA and the HANA data
modeling, you're familiar
with calculation views.
So we consume this data
as part of a calc view,
and then expose that
through a visualization
using SAP Analytics Cloud.
So here, I'm looking at the
configuration for my file.
So here, I'm using a CSV file.
And the CSV file is in a
root path, SAP Data Hub.
Now I switch to my
Google GCS, and I'm just
pointing to the
location where I have
my source file that I'll be
using for this demo exercise.
And as the next step,
I'm going to point
to the Google
Pub/Sub and the sync
where I have mentioned
the information.
So the topic where I'm capturing
this information in the Google
Pub/Sub.
So as data is being
streamed in through this,
now I can go in and
capture the data.
So I also have this terminal.
So what you see
here is a terminal
where I can capture the
data that's coming in.
So the data that
is being streamed
through the point-of-sale
devices is being streamed here.
And within Data Hub, I
can add a terminal window
to actually see what
data is being streamed.
So the idea here is
not to really read
through that stream,
but we're just
showing you how you can also
look at the actual data being
streamed in.
And we also have an integration
with Stackdriver from GCP
to analyze the monitoring
of this information,
so how much data is
being streamed in
at specific intervals of time?
So if I switch to the
pipeline, primarily here,
I'm looking at, what data
is being streamed in?
And then, where I'm being
able to capture that
into a Google BigQuery.
So now that I have the
data being streamed in,
I'm looking at Google
BigQuery, and I'm
looking at the data that's being
streamed in real time here.
So I'm just running a query to
show that the number of rows
are increasing.
So it was around 8,000 earlier,
and now it's at 16,840.
So this is primarily
showing that I
am streaming this data
from Google Pub/Sub, built
this pipeline using Data Hub.
And then in the
next step, I'm going
to be consuming this as part
of a HANA calculation view,
where I consume this Google
BigQuery as a virtual table,
and then make that available
through SAP HANA Smart Data
access.
So this is where I'm using
the Google BigQuery table.
I consume that as a virtual
table using that logical data
warehousing concept,
and then make
that available
for my BI analysis
through HANA calculation views.
In the next step, I'm
doing some visualization.
I'm not going to talk too
much about the visualization,
because once you've done
the heavy lifting in terms
of building that pipeline, which
is where the meat of the work
happens, which is where a
data engineer comes in and has
to do the different parts,
in terms of configuring
my different sources, in this
case being Google Pub/Sub,
and then making that data
available through Google
BigQuery, and finally expose
that into a HANA table.
AMOGH UMBARKAR: If we have
time, I can do that [INAUDIBLE]..
We have 24 minutes, right?
OK.
BALAJI KRISHNA: So let me
switch to the other demo.
Well, I can show
a few more screens
of SAP Data Hub and
its capabilities.
All right.
So what you see here is
the Data Hub cockpit.
This is kind of the UI for
an administrator, where
he or she comes in and
sets up the landscape.
So in terms of the
landscape, I want
to create different systems.
I want to set up these
zones where I can categorize
the different systems.
So I'm providing a connection
here to my HANA system,
or it could be to my ERP
system, or a Hadoop system.
I have the options of
setting up the systems
depending on the source systems
that I have to connect to.
So here you see a list
of the different systems
I've connected to.
And then as the next
step, I can go in there
and I can browse through
the different data points
that we have.
So in my case, I'm going to
go through a data discovery
exercise.
So here, I have the option
of browsing through my Hadoop
connections.
So I can browse
through an HDFS folder,
and I can look at the
different files in there,
Parquet files, ORC
files, CSV files.
Or if I want to connect through
a GCP or any cloud storage,
I have the same option.
In this exercise, I'm just going
to go through a HANA system,
and I'm going to browse
through a HANA view
that I'm going to then run
through a data profiling task.
So I have information
here for the sales order.
So now I'm in the data
discovery or data profiling
space, where I'm looking
at the data that I have.
So this is just a sample data.
And this is where the data
wrangling part kind of
kicks in.
So you want to get
introduced to, hey,
now I want to do a data
wrangling kind of exercise.
Before that, I
want to understand
the spread of the data.
So I want to look at the
profiling information
in the factsheet,
where I can see,
what are the different
values of the data?
What is the spread of
data, say, in terms
of what are the distinct values?
So here I go to the
factsheet, and I
can look at the
different data points,
or have information
about, this has
around 1.9 million
unique sales information,
around 20,000 customers,
5,000 products,
terms of the master data for
my customer and products,
who purchase this
specific product.
And I have the data
for three years.
Depending on the data
points that you have,
or depending on the source--
for example, if it
is a Parquet file--
obviously you'll have
a much larger data set.
And in a lot of
our customers, they
want to store the cold data in
a Hadoop system or a data lake
system, so the profiling task
for a Hadoop system, or even
for a cloud system, can be
enabled similar to what you're
seeing here from a HANA table.
Now I enter into the
Pipeline Modeler.
So the idea here is, as a data
engineer or a data modeler,
or even a data
scientist, you want
to understand the data a little
bit before you can really
play around with the data.
So if you are a data
scientist, you're
using the Jupyter Notebooks,
or IPython Notebooks.
In our case, we provide
this Data Hub tool,
where you have a UI-enabled
way of dragging and dropping
information and trying
to build your pipelines.
So here, you're
looking at a pipeline
where we've used the data that
we got from the sales order
table, and we're running
some predictive algorithms.
In this case, we're going to
be using Python initially.
And in the next phase,
we're going to be using R.
So we'll show you how you
can very easily modify
your predictive algorithms
to suit whatever
you are comfortable with.
So if you are a
TensorFlow customer,
you can just strip and
replace a Python algorithm
with a TensorFlow algorithm, and
you can enable the prediction.
So we have two tasks here.
One is training the
algorithm, and the other one
is the serving part.
And now I'm showing you
how we build a training
algorithm using Python.
So I'm opening up my
SQL generator, which
is where I'm getting the
data from my HANA system,
so the sales order
table that you just saw.
I'm going to bring
in that data, and I'm
going to convert
that to a CSV format,
so that I can feed that
to my Python model,
so that it can take
that data and then do
analysis on that Python model.
So we leverage some of
the open-source libraries,
like Pandas and [INAUDIBLE]
So again, I can bring in
any external algorithm.
I can make that available
as part of my pipeline,
and leverage the insights
that I get out of that.
So what you're
seeing here is, this
is called a graph, or a
pipeline, within Data Hub.
And each of those blocks
are the operators.
So we deliver around
200-plus operators
to do different
tasks, whether it's
you want to anonymize
the data in-flight,
you want to do
data cleansing, you
want to do geocoding,
reverse geocoding,
you want to enable location
intelligence on top of that,
or you, as a partner, want
to build your own operator.
We provide all
those capabilities
as part of Data Hub,
and extend that even
to machine learning
and AI as well.
So I'm just showing some
open-source libraries
that I'm importing from Pandas.
This is the Python
library that we've
written for doing the
predictive analysis based
on the sales orders data.
So just switching
through the demo.
So what I have here is,
when I execute this,
I'm training this model.
So there is first the training
phase, which I'm doing.
And then, once I've
trained it, I'm
going to serve the
model so that I
can apply this model on
new data that's coming in,
or real-time data
that's coming in,
to be able to get a prediction
out of that real-time data.
So let me quickly
move through this.
So basically, what you're
seeing here is right now,
I have the train model,
or the serving model.
So I've used the Python
serve model here.
And I'm going to be
loading the data that I
got from my trained ML model.
I'm going to feed that through
this prediction Python,
and then get a prediction.
So based on the inputs that you
provide for this prediction,
you'll be able to get a
prediction from that model
saying, depending on the
customer and their buying
pattern, if I provide
number of days,
there is a high probability
that the customer is going
to buy another similar product.
So here I'm picking up
the customer ID, customer
information, and the product.
And then I specify the day.
And based on the
number of days, it's
going to tell me, what's the
probability that the customer
might buy a product?
So this is, again, based on the
historic information about what
this customer has bought.
There's a certain level of
recommendation capabilities
as well.
So when I punch in 50 days,
there's 1.51 times probability.
When I punch in 500
days, there's a 14 times
probability that the customer
might buy this product.
So now I switch from
using a Python algorithm
to a R algorithm.
So we'll show you
how easy it is.
So we've already
created a graph.
So what we do is, first,
we copy this pipeline.
So I already have a pipeline.
So this is the whole
reusability part
of how a developer can reuse
pipelines that are already
existing in your repository.
So I'm just going to call
this with a different name.
I'm going to call it Train
for R. And then I go in.
I remove this.
So I'm just literally going
to delete that operator.
And I'm going to drag
and drop a R operator.
So obviously, depending on--
and like you see there
on the left side,
it could be a TensorFlow
operator as well.
So here I'm looking at the
code from a R standpoint.
So this is a custom code
that I've written for R.
And then I just have to connect
my operator to the input data
feed that I'm
getting, and then I'll
be ready to train this
graph using the new R
operator, R code, that I just
inserted into this pipeline.
So I just have to make
some changes in terms
of what the model name is.
I'll go through that.
It's a similar exercise as
we did in the previous time.
Now I'm running the train model.
Once I complete this,
in the next step,
I'm going to bring
in the serve model.
So I'm going to
do the same thing.
So here I have the
Python-based serve model.
I'm just going to save
it as a different name,
and then literally drop that
operator, add a R operator,
and then use that for
serving this graph,
so that you can see the
prediction difference.
And this is something that
data scientists would always
want to do, because there's
always something new coming in
from the different
libraries, so you
want to ensure that you can
get as close a prediction
to real time.
All right.
So I'm just going to drop that.
I'm bringing in
the R serve model.
And then I'm going to
connect to the model
that I created using my R train.
Do the same prediction now.
So I switch from 50
days to 500 days,
and you see, in
the previous one,
it was 14 times probability.
Now it's 17 times probability.
So you as a data scientist,
you have some tools
that you can play around
with, in terms of,
this is your favorite algorithm.
So you can do some kind
of analysis based on that.
So I just wanted to
show a live system,
so that you guys don't
think we are just showing
you some recorded demos.
So again, what you're seeing
here is the Data Hub homepage.
So this is the latest version
of the homepage, which
will be available for customers
end of this week, I think.
So this is the new version.
So we have multiple
applications.
So what you are seeing right
now is the [INAUDIBLE] modeler,
which is what I have here,
or the Data Hub modeler,
which is the Pipeline Modeler.
And we also introduce other
things like metadata explorers.
So one of the big
things that we're
seeing from a lot of
customers, and again, there
are several startups
that are trying
to solve this problem,
the capability
to provide metadata management,
data cataloging, lineage,
impact analysis, across the
different disparate data
sources.
And again, it's not
just limited to,
I have my data in SAP systems.
I can do lineage.
No.
Talking about
lineage all the way
from your BI report,
whether it is a Tableau
dashboard or an
SAP Analytics Cloud
dashboard, all the way
to the SAP ERP system.
So those are things that we can
do from a Data Hub standpoint.
So we are bringing in
multiple capabilities
into a single tool,
so that you don't
have to go look at different
tools to do different things.
And all these are available as
part of Google Cloud Platform.
And we have customers that Amogh
is going to be talking about,
in terms of the use cases.
So I'm going to
pause there, and I'm
going to pass it back to Amogh.
AMOGH UMBARKAR: Yeah,
thank you, Balaji.
I think one more thing also.
Our board member,
[INAUDIBLE] and Diane
have also announced that we are
able to sprout in 30 minutes,
if you want to try out SAP
Data Hub on Google Cloud
Platform using Kubernetes.
And super.
I'll just walk you briefly
through couple use cases,
just starting with one
of the customers who
has a [INAUDIBLE] right
now, ATB Financial.
Here is how they are
also bringing out
the kind of benefits they see.
Their goal was to have zero
dissatisfied customers.
They have seen a huge
increase in efficiency,
for their operations and
delivery, by 30% to 40%.
This is where they
were able to bring out
their data-driven approach.
We have been discussing couple
use cases with them as well.
Also, they are working
with the Google Cloud team.
They are trying to set up a
data science lab in there.
They are having
also on-prem, HANA,
and Hadoop kind of a set-up,
and multiple use cases,
including customer
satisfaction, how
can they enrich the
customer experience,
or also try and bring out
more and more customer churn
scenarios, so that way,
they are able to predict
what product from them is
bringing out what impact.
Another customer of ours
is also able to use now
machine learning, as well
as predictive analysis.
We give a lot of operators,
as you saw from the demos
Balaji gave you.
I think there are over 220-plus.
As we go on, we are embracing
everything that's available.
And you can include then,
the seamless integration
towards SAP [INAUDIBLE]
for HANA as well.
You can have different
zones set up,
one for data science, one
towards data management or data
engineers, and have that
seamless flow and orchestration
of data as you will.
Of course, you want to see--
Balaji already demonstrated--
how once the model is proven,
you can easily bring
that into production,
or industrialize that model.
And then, another nice
story of a customer, we
have seen all the
smart appliances
and connected world and so on.
Here, we saw a customer
giving us a challenge.
There were 6 million
devices generating
16 terabytes of data per day.
They had a first challenge.
Their data science team,
they were paying top dollar
for that kind of
data science team.
And they ended up using four
or five different tools.
Now, we shell out thousands
of dollars for these.
And their idea was to see that
whatever features are coming
out from that, they wanted
to get a good production
efficiency.
They saw the usage of that.
They were able to
bring all that data in.
But there were a lot of issues.
You know, there were
five different tools.
There was a lot
of manual coding.
There was no
automation possible.
And there was no
end-to-end visibility.
They did not know where
the data was stuck,
or where it was not
running on to a good model.
With SAP Data Hub,
what we changed,
we refined complete end-to-end
process using one single tool.
We were able to give them a nice
visual modeling environment.
We also brought in governance.
We understood their process and
then helped them automate that.
From one region, they
were able to scale out
into multiple regions as well.
And we were completely
helping them
in the end-to-end orchestration
and refining their data.
So they were not only
able to bring down
that from the 10 features
that were given out
in this new appliance, whether
only three of them were used,
they pushed a campaign.
And out of that came
in use of four more.
But then persistently, they saw
that in all different regions,
three were not being
used, then they
stopped the production of those,
because it was not being used.
At the same time, they also
were matching that data
with the enterprise data in SAP.
All these kind of raw streaming
data came in together.
If you or me are paying
thousands of dollars for this,
we want to see that
it is not lying around
for three to four months,
when the service vendor comes
and gives us service, right?
So we were able
to bring the data,
mash it up with the
customer information,
with the vendor information.
Then, based on the
error code, they
were able to
proactively reach out
to the service
vendor in that area
and say that please
carry part ABC.
And more than 85% of the
times, in one single visit,
they were able to
resolve the issues
and had a very loyal customer.
Another quick example is
about how the fitness tracker
data is there.
Most of us are using
wearable devices.
And we were able to now
stream data from there
across the globe.
We were able to bring
in the sales figures.
We were able to bring in
what type of, for example,
jogging shoe or running shoe
was used by that consumer.
And not only that, but
when we refined all these,
we were able to help
them deliver insights.
We were able to then bring
this data towards an analytics
dashboard, and bring
out, with the model
that, based on the
pattern, or the jogging
pattern of the consumer, and
the type of shoe they have,
they were able to bring out
much more sale opportunities,
more than 20% in some regions.
So that way, they were able to
increase their sales as well.
And then, very
briefly, you heard also
from our board member,
[INAUDIBLE] in the morning.
Here is how SAP is trying
to bring out more--
how simplified data management
can be in the future.
Together with SAP HANA, that is
what is our SAP data management
suite.
Data Hub is one of the
significant components in that.
And as you have
seen already, we are
able to scale out into our
partners, like Google Cloud
and also others.
What we are also
trying to deliver now,
in terms of our
strategy, is gear up all
of you towards an
intelligent enterprise.
And there, in the digital
platform, of course,
is driven through SAP
HANA, and the SAP Data Hub
is then the core of
the data management,
where we are wanting
to help you in all
the multi-cloud
environments, and have
that seamless flow
of data, manage
and give you a wonderful
customer experience as well.
And just a brief
takeaway, if you will,
how SAP Data Hub is
then going to help
you bring in a kind
of consolidated view
across all the sources of
data, how it is going to help
bring in intelligent discovery.
As we move ahead, we will
be able to help you also
more and more with improvised
data quality and cleansing.
We will be able to help
you with kind of enrichment
of the data, how we can
have distributed processing
across these kind of
hyperscale architectures,
how we can help you with kind
of scalable data ops management.
As we move into the
cloud, you heard as well,
in the keynote in the
morning, that is where they
want to automate more and more.
And last but not the least, also
get optimal and compliant data
governance across
the enterprise,
even for the data that is
now becoming more and more
relevant, the unstructured
one, how you can
help get more grip over that.
Here are some of the resources
which are available for you.
Please note the links.
And of course, you can reach
out to SAP as well through here,
and we'll be happy
to help you in that.
Thank you very much.
Please do not forget to also
give feedback on the app.
And we'll open up the round
for any questions now.
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]